wait I don't know that this where why is
it on order Jake what did you do so we
did an episode where we were looking at
future JavaScript stuff we did it well
people like that
yes so why if what we do is look at new
stuff that's already landed oh I thought
we're gonna say let's look at old stuff
I'm like well I think new stuff that's
already landed is is probably how you
would define old stuff really I feel
like I'm doing a bad job of introducing
what this actually is so I'm just going
to look at es 3 let's well yes oh I was
trying to make a joke don't ever do that
again just tell me what what is going on
here this is this is like the throwback
to object or in the programming in
JavaScript before we had classes isn't
it exactly yeah
where you like you could define a
function and suddenly you can add
properties on the prototype of that
function it sounds really weird but
that's how you did so what what's
happening so you define a function car
yeah I'm not gonna look talk about
what's inside the function for now but
then you can add things on the prototype
of this function called car and I think
that prototype is used when you create
use the function with the new keyword so
if I say new car then the things on the
prototype in that thing I can use also
in the instance of Carta was a really
bad explanation it was because but also
it's I always had a confusing like it's
in its I was it called in prototypical
inheritance yes something like that
prototype whole prototypical they input
what about so I'm not you just already
doing weird stuff this is this so I
guess we should explain that you you are
relatively recent to the web but yeah
Graham took fast oh yeah I never would
have never done I've done it at
university not that specific I just used
car dot prototype dot first function
equals and then a function but this car
inherits from vehicle and this is how we
used to do in Harrisons but that's
disgusting it
yes isn't it isn't it horrible ow
because
I mean that's what people use frameworks
right or that little little libraries
that would give you that exactly and so
because you want the you want car dot
prototype to be an instance of vehicle
but vehicle has you need to call the
function where stuff it has options and
things so what you need to do is create
a new constructor copy the prototype
over a reference to prototype over
creating new one of those and that meant
your car now inherits from vehicle and
then here this is where you were doing
the the super call my point is like a
classes this is what we have yeah I mean
so this is what I want to talk about is
is just there's some of the things that
we've got now if we take me for granted
almost isn't it and we almost take for
granted it reminded the old version the
per typically herons always reminds me
of Lua where you only have tables and
you have tables within tables if you
want to inherit it just get super weird
it feels very similar and this is just
feels better never done lower I'll take
your word for it what's happening here
you will finding a function called spin
correct let's take a closer look so the
options up okay so this is basically
sanitization of the options object yam
which you know even there's also
libraries where you just define in a
syntax what the options object should
look like because otherwise you would
have to write this and this is just like
it took me well to actually understand
what you were doing and now I didn't
read every detail because I recognized
the pattern because I've written that
before yes if you don't know the pattern
this would be a lot of reading time
spent until you know oh you're just
checking that certain properties are
present and if they're not using the
default value yes and this got a lot
easier with object or a sign which was
essentially what the library yeah - we
all had a you know and I be doing
something like object assign and that's
what we'd use here but nowadays
destructor ring with the fault values
yes so what we see here we're d
structuring we were giving it default
values and then a default value for the
option object there so it's entirely
optional but I I brought this example
for a reason
because I don't like it because you
don't like it I I do like the structure
into followers I have gotten around it a
little bit I don't like it in the actual
function parameter definition I prefer
this
yes where the structure in a separate
place because otherwise it's like it
gets a little bit nested and it looks a
bit cramped and especially if you have
type scripts it gets even weirder
because then you the types just go all
over the place so sudden right now he's
type script I often have a type it's
called function name where the word
options append it to the end where I
define what structure the options object
have and then I have the first line in
my function will then assign the default
values yeah and and I agree I yeah this
looks a lot neater the reason I would
still do this is because a static
analyzer knows that this these are the
properties of the option object in this
case true it's not so that's basic this
is basic probably before a preferable if
you don't have touched right so that's
that what's happening here if you don't
know what's happening here
way to get out we have fire yeah you
were making the Dom element with a class
whatever be a hundred percent of pixel
pixel tall well saved so I spend a lot
of my time designing in dev tools yeah
I'll put some raw some rough styles just
into the editor and then I'll go into
dev tools and that's where I'll be
shifting vowels around to make it look
then at the end of copy and paste yeah
in this case editing this and dev tools
is hard because what I want in this case
I want whatever to be the same width as
it is high like I want it to only be
square is how a human would say that
yeah and it means that if I'm like
shifting values around in dev tools I
shift one and then I have to tab twice
or whatever and shift the other one and
that's a pain so here's one of the
solution yes that's the proper solution
they'd say yeah and it's been nice now
that this is supported in like all
modern browsers yeah I've just found
this a dream and it's it's whatever the
size is coming to CSS is that right and
it's an alias for width plus height yeah
that's exciting
yeah because we have it a lot of other
things for example I think background
image size or certain other size
properties
where you can have one value or two
values and if it's only one value it's
the same for width and height but we
don't have it for the actual size comes
a shortcut for width and height and you
can also do size one or the pixel 200
pixels if you want it to be one of the
pixels widened in the same way you do
some background size exam right okay
that's good but in the meantime this one
else this works yeah right what's
happening here you haven't I'm assuming
at ul now I are well-named variables and
you're not trying to throw me off so you
have a list that you add a click handler
and then you get the event targets from
the Li and if it's not an Li then you
say well oh you bubble up okay so what
you're doing is you you basically do the
event delegation we have one click
handler on the ult of like each
individual list item and then you try to
figure out on the click event what is
the actual list item if you click on it
so one event listener on the list yeah
but you're using it to detect a click on
all the list item so that means you can
move those list items around add and
remove them you don't have to change it
but then the problem becomes that if
your list item has like an anchor tag
that event or target might be the anchor
tag within the list item well it might
just be the list itself or it was not
self click to list item so and then what
you have to do is you actually have to
walk up the tree manually to find what
the containing list element is if it
exists yeah and I always found this it's
only a little bit of code but it always
felt like a barrier to using event
delegation
where is now closest and it's so good
because it doesn't have to be a tag name
yeah today supercharged episode is oh
wait I did oh right yeah I did worried
that maybe there's gonna be a lot of
crossover between on what I show now and
supercharged oh yeah this is just
because as far as I know closest was
inspired by jQuery
well indeed the jQuery series well there
might be some of those coming up as well
let's carry on what is happening here
good luck all right wait all right so
you're you're replacing just a plus
because that's the writes with no
anything before the plus will that match
pluses yes I would be a literal plus
yeah oh that is yeah infusing this you
see the plus means the preceding matcher
one
or many times repeated but if there's no
preceding matter I'm pretty sure that
works some of these I haven't checked
thoroughly I'm sure I was probably
backslash it for clarity anyway unless
it then breaks because right axis okay
we were placing pluses with spaces yeah
and then we have a result oh you are
totally parsing URLs aren't you yes I am
well specifically the query string the
query string yeah because you're there
space spaces are encoded it's pluses and
the individual parameters are separated
by ampersands and then you do the
equality split then actually in the end
oh you do the URI component decode that
is a lot of work it's a lot of work and
it looks are you in ok exam stream it's
the browse I can't actually encoding and
doing it yourself is super frustrating
exactly and it's useful to look at the
URL decide stuff it could I would be the
current URL or it could be the URL of a
link or it could be some form data that
you're trying to say because it's the
same encoding and having to do this to
figure it out the URL search parents
it's I yeah it's just so much nicer that
we have that now and we have that across
all modern browsers it's all very
annoyed that they didn't add a new
property onto the location object so do
you know why so it is on if you do new
URL and pass a URL in you now have URL
search parameters yeah which is an
instance of this which is representing
which is a string the problem is the
location object is available across
windows also if I open a window I can
get access to that yeah and even if that
window is in a number process like an
iframe you still have access to the
location object okay and this has been
the whole problem of implementing that
is having this this extra object that
exists and that's not a problem well
because we have window proxy right and
so we would need the equivalent of a
search parameter because of things like
expand O's and all of that sort of stuff
it's not referencing exactly the same
object I hope you find we just defined
getter function that like just gives me
a new instance in the same realm or
something and it's it's just like every
time I do like new URL search a new URL
and then location to string or something
and just
yeah yeah exactly but it's a small world
compared to what we had to do before
agrees it's it's workaround able but it
would be nice if it was there but yeah
this this you know get a set as it does
the encoding the decoding and it's just
there and it's brilliant excellent so ah
fire reader yeah yeah that was I
it's I'm I'm not sure about fire so it
like was supposed to help you read blobs
and files that are given from like file
pickers and these kind of things and
it's like this super non promised based
API which are always great it's like xhr
but for files in a way yeah yeah I feel
like it's a support like super flaky
across browser this is actually this is
well supported as you say it predates
promises it will take a blob or a file
because file inherits from blog if you
want it to take that because blob is you
don't get access to the bytes you want
access to the bytes as like you know
texts or an array buffer yeah this is
the mess you would have to deal with
nowadays yes and I say something that
you recently taught me oh you never
thought about abusing response in that
way I don't think it's actually abused
well it's creating a response when you
don't really need to just because it has
these methods on it suddenly promise
based much more cause it is actually you
know what's going on and the game gets a
big difference and that's one of the
things when we design the response API
we wanted to be very easy to yeah get
these of a formats out like text array
buffer things and nice promise based API
obviously async functions are a thing we
didn't used to have that I take for
granted now in all major browsers so
much easier right this is the last one
wait what if you can at least get a
flavor for what's um what's going on
here we are getting is creating a styles
object we're creating a random animation
[Music]
generating the animation I'll go with is
a wide translation we add the new styles
then we add that new animation to an
object wait for draw I'll say I'll save
you time this is if you're wanting to
create a program
like animation I see because back in the
day you only had CSS yes so if I wanted
to animate from something to something
else this is the kind of thing I have to
do I have to you create a keyframe
Hedgehog keyframe animation add it as a
style tag and this is because like an
animation could end or it could cancel
so I need to listen for both to know
when the animation is done and do turn
that into a promise and I know there are
tada web animations API it's finally
coming to a point where it becomes
usable across browsers
yeah and this is this is themed
differently from the other examples
because we still don't have this and
it's well we have it in Chrome at least
a subset we don't have the finished
promise no we don't we saw that's true
and you know whose fault that is well by
extension yes it's my fault because at
the time they designed this it was we
hadn't decided what to do with Constable
promises at the time and because
finished is a cat is a promise that may
cancel
I put the brakes on I said like we can't
ship this yet because it might be turn
out to be in glaze and gentlemen please
tweet at Jake I'm sorry and you know
what's worse the thing they were doing
is what we ended up doing so we shipped
it would have been fine but well I used
to do a JavaScript library for the BBC
and we were having to target things like
safari 1.3 and it's the this is the sort
of stuff all this stuff actually I was
killed for this stuff back then and it's
is nice to see that you know we look at
the future cool stuff that might land
it's like oh that looks interesting and
it's nice to stop and look like things
have got better we've got nice things in
our things I've got that I tend to on
stage i lock my arms in but not
different let my friend I walk around
just like a camp zombie here I think it
might be that yeah sighs I have a leg so
I'm talking here X mode engaged
I think on my keyboard driving my car